food doesn't last in days sometimes
hours bread goes moldy apple slices turn
brown and bacteria multiply in
mayonnaise but you can find all of these
foods out on the shelf at the grocery
store
hopefully unspoiled thanks to
preservatives but what exactly are
preservatives how do they help keep food
edible and are they safe there are two
major factors that cause food to go bad
microbes and oxidation microbes like
bacteria and fungi invade food and feed
off its nutrients some of these can
cause diseases like Listeria and
botulism others just turn edibles into a
smelly slimy moldy mess meanwhile
oxidation is a chemical change in the
foods molecules caused by enzymes or
free radicals which turn fats rancid and
brown produce like apples and potatoes
preservatives can prevent both types of
deterioration before the invention of
artificial refrigeration fungi and
bacteria could run rampant in food so we
found ways to create an inhospitable
environment for microbes for example
making the food more acidic unravels
enzymes that microbes need to survive
and some types of bacteria can actually
help for thousands of years people
preserved food using bacteria that
produce lactic acid the acid turns
perishable vegetables and milk into
longer-lasting foods like sauerkraut in
Europe kimchi in Korea and yogurt in the
Middle East these cultured foods also
populate your digestive tract with
beneficial microbes many synthetic
preservatives are also acids benzoic
acid in salad dressing sorbic acid in
cheese and propionic acid in baked goods
are they safe
some studies suggest that benzoate
related to benzoic acid contribute to
hyperactive behavior but the results
aren't conclusive otherwise these acids
seem to be perfectly safe
another antimicrobial strategy is to add
a lot of sugar like in Jam or salt like
in salted meats sugar and salt hold on
to water that microbes need to grow and
actually suck moisture out of any cells
that may be hanging around thus
destroying them of course too much sugar
and salt can increase your risk of heart
disease diabetes and high blood pressure
so these preservatives are best in
moderation anti microbial nitrates and
nitrites often found in cured meats ward
off the bacteria that cause botulism but
they may cause other health problems
some studies linking cured meats to
cancer have suggested that these
preservatives may be the culprit
meanwhile antioxidant preservatives
prevent the chemical changes that can
give food and off flavor or color smoke
has been used to preserve food for
millennia because some of the aromatic
compounds in wood smoke are antioxidants
combining smoking with salting was an
effective way of preserving meat before
refrigeration for antioxidant activity
without a smoky flavor
there are compounds like BHT and
tocopheryl better known as vitamin E
like the compounds in smoke
these Saba free radicals and stave off
rancid flavors that can develop in foods
like oils cheese and cereal other
antioxidants like citric acid and a
sorbic acid help cut produce keep its
color by thwarting the enzyme that
causes browning some compounds like
sulfites can multitask
they're both anti microbials and
antioxidants sulfites may cause allergy
symptoms in some people but most
antioxidant preservatives are generally
recognized as safe so should you be
worried about preservatives well they're
usually near the end of the ingredients
list because they're used in very small
amounts determined by the FDA to be safe
nevertheless some consumers and
companies are trying to find
alternatives packaging tricks like
reducing the oxygen around the food can
help but without some kind of chemical
assistance
there are very few foods that can stay
shelf stable for long